pendant ce temps pierre et dominique
arrive ta mère en arrière attention la
séquence qui vient est digne des
transformers bon ben maintenant faut
l'installer la salle de cinéma
oui et l'ensemble du convoi pèse plus de
10 tonnes pourvu que pierre ce soit bien
entraîné c'est pas le moment de faire de
l'asthme
on commence par où on va ouvrir les
verrouillages de toi ok comme ça ça va
nous permettre à près de l'ouvrir
d'élargir le ouvrir la salle on va
baisser la suspension vous voyez pas là
on est sur un parking qui en pente il
faut pas être dans une salle de cinéma
comme ça pendant deux heures c'est pas
génial
du coup il faut rééquilibrer le camion
tous après faut un branchement sur les
communes en france
q
voilà ça y est je vois enfin ce cinéma
est donc là tu vois il ya des sièges
normale à la verticale en train de
décembre
nos stars wars star wars mais aussi
clouzot cassavettes le ciné mobile
projette tous les cinémas
parce que le cinéma c'est aussi notre
patrimoine commun il en faut pour tous
les goûts
on sera serré quoi normalement non non à
desalle est énorme
[Musique]
voilà si celle ci était à la verticale
il y a quinze secondes maintenant et à
plat et tu peux regarder un film
tranquillou oui enfin il reste un détail
l'écran reste a quand même un écran en
milieu de la salle
bon sang ça évite de mettre les gants
dessus ces projets même les mains donc
là un petit bureau gac
vraiment multifonctions quoi conducteur
installateurs de salles femme de ménage
par deux caissiers un petit service
d'ordre
[Musique]
non
tu as une énorme machine j'imagine que
c'est ça qui sert à projeter les films
ouais lortal projecteurs ok le do ré mi
c'est le gros disque dur c'est là où
sont stockés les films c'est la
bibliothèque quand que j'ai dans le
camion
bon bah la salle est prête elle est
prête maintenant on retrouve tout à
l'heure pour une séance avec 60 jeunes
à tout à l'heure
[Musique]